so today I want to talk about the
relationship between your mood and your
food there's a huge relationship the
problem is that you never ever ever ever
ever want to treat a symptom directly
without understanding the underlying
cause and that's the problem of medicine
is they treat all the symptoms so if you
get depression they're going to treat it
they don't ask why anxiety it's a
treatment there's a lot of pills there's
no profit in curing these it's all about
managing these symptoms in fact when you
treat the symptom or you diagnose
incorrectly you make the patient worse
I'll give an example I had a patient who
was depressed and I said when we when we
depressed she goes when I was diagnosed
I said interesting I said I started
questioning more stuff and I said you
know what you're not depressed you're
just exhausted she goes wow that makes
sense because I don't sleep I feel
better thank you so I got rid of her
depression just by helping her realize
the underlying cause okay so let's talk
about this there's a couple of factors
and in the relationship to in affecting
your emotional mood and the food that
you eat and other things let's talk
about nutrition nutrition first you hear
the concept an apple a day keeps the
doctor away well that might have been
true in 1965 but not now it takes six
apples a day now to keep the doctor away
if you take the apples and shoot them
hard enough at the doctor I'm just
kidding don't do that but the point is
that it there soils are so bad right now
you need so much food to achieve the
same nutrient levels in Europe or in
Africa the food nutritional factors are
so much more that that's why they have
good teeth good bone structure because
they have more nutrition in the soils so
the soils are bad in America that's the
food is empty so therefore you need to
eat even healthier let's just take
potassium it's one of the most important
minerals in a good relaxed body because
potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it calms the nervous system
down and you might say that you eat a
banana a day
well that's 400 milligrams you need 4700
milligrams
just to get your minimum so that would
equate to about
seven to eight to even ten cups of
vegetables or salad every single day how
many cups the vegetables are you eating
every day so potassium is very very
important for two reasons to calm the
heart rate down because if your
potassium is low your pulse rate is
going to go high try to sleep with your
pulse rate just going boom boom boom
boom
it won't let you relax so potassium is
very important to calm the heart down
it's also important to establish good
blood sugars and even to help stabilize
the sugar so they don't drop down too
far we'll get into that in a second but
I want to just talk about the nutrient
factors B vitamins especially b1 B
vitamins are used up when you're in a
stress State so when you're pushing your
body and you're stressed out you're
going to deplete your B vitamins
especially b1 and some of the other ones
when you deplete B vitamins you become
more anxious you have that internal that
restlessness restless leg syndrome for
example is a B vitamin deficiency the
best source of B vitamin E steel fist or
get nutritional yeast take a teaspoon I
like to put it in plain yogurt put in
your calcium whatever but those B
vitamins are very very very important to
actually calm you down and help you
sleep and prevent nightmares as well but
don't buy them from a one-a-day vitamin
most these vitamins out there are
synthetic and you don't want to consume
synthetic vitamins you want them food
base I have one called super nutrients
that I use because it has good cognitive
function it's all food base
there's no synthetics and you could take
probably three of those and get enough B
vitamins if you wanted to do that called
super nutrients calcium calcium is
important to help you relax calm down
and reduce stress when you're under
stress you deplete your calcium calcium
goes through you you don't really absorb
it as well so calcium the best source is
not from a typical one a day or some of
the calcium supplements they sell at CVS
because all those are made from calcium
carbonate that's limestone be better off
chewing on the cement outside and I
won't mention any brand names that
use calcium carbonate sometimes silver
but a lot of these top name-brand
calciums they basically used rocks which
don't absorb so you need a calcium
citrate or have it from cheese or have
it from plain yogurt something like that
okay omega-3 very very important in
cognitive function and even especially
for children
so omega-3 fish oils for kids oh my gosh
huge but the problem is that there's
something fishy about fish oils and that
would be that it's usually rancid so get
a higher quality fish oil rather than
just kind of like the cheapest brand
that you can find get a good one and
open up the capsule and smell it and if
it's not visually it might be it's
probably pretty good so if you're going
to go with fish oils make sure it's a
higher quality okay so that's one thing
and then I'm going to talk about iodine
when a child is growing or when you're
nursing or when you're going to have a
baby make sure that you consume enough
iodine as from a seek seek help source I
like sea kelp that's the best source of
iodine and like especially pregnant
females and things like that because
iodine supports the thyroid children
that are mentally [ __ ] usually I
have an iodine deficiency because the
mother was deficient and it transported
over to the baby and i neva know some
adults that are mentally [ __ ] as
well because they don't have enough
iodine iodine supports the thyroid the
thyroid helps the cognitive function of
the brain but I like to have it from the
food base not a synthetic or like a rock
so take it from sea kelp
next thing blood sugar is very very
important if your blood sugar is not
perfectly level at 100 if it goes too
high you're going to get brain fog
you're going to have loss of memory when
the blood sugars go down you're going to
have irritability a DD you're going to
be edgy so just from blood sugars so the
blood sugar relationship to t between
cognitive function on a physical level
it's it's huge it's very very important
I used to have brain fog all the time
and then one day
I started to change my breakfast from a
carbohydrate cereal to a protein
breakfast I think I was having buffalo
burger or even a piece of fish and then
I went to eggs oh my gosh I felt so much
better like a like a helmet lifted off
my head so you want to make sure your
breakfast is protein because that
actually stabilizes the blood sugars
through the whole day if you skip a meal
skip breakfast or have a carb breakfast
in the evening you're going to have low
blood sugars now having low blood sugars
doesn't mean you're just you should eat
more sugar it just means that you didn't
set it up where you have good protein in
salad or vegetables in that potassium to
stabilize your sugar so when your blood
Sugar's drop down have a salad have some
don't eat sugar that's not going to fix
it and so we want to make sure that we
don't eat sugars because it's going to
spike and then come down you're going to
help with a low blood sugar and then
you're going to irritable so the bottom
line is you have to avoid sugar okay
seven cups of salad we talked about
potassium will help stabilize your blood
Sugar's and it's great for diabetics
protein breakfast very very very
important that kale shake and get the
recipe off the website kale shake in the
morning is wonderful to establish the
blood sugars through the whole day
hormones hormones influence your brain
as well serotonin it's a pleasure
hormone and that's how psych drugs work
too they recycle that last drop of
serotonin you have over and over and
over again tricking your body and
thinking it has more than it really does
so when you take these psych drugs they
end up causing a deficiency over the
time even more and the need for that
medication Rises over time so it doesn't
have a long-term good solution and
sometimes when the doctor doesn't have a
plan to get you off the medication then
you end up mean more and more and more
on different ones and to the point where
it really ruins the body so you want to
start building up serotonin with a good
diet before you even get these symptoms
now next thing is cortisol that's the
stress hormone and that comes from all
types of stress you push yourself over
the years you work two jobs you don't
sleep maybe you don't take care of your
maybe you party too much and you go into
the flooded fight mode and you will get
anxiety as a symptom from cortisol so
anxiety worry thinking all the time
that's a higher cortisol adrenaline
adrenal problem which needs to be
improved through natural means one ways
is through walking each day through
maybe acupressure stretching pulling the
stress out or sleeping or keeping the
diet good or avoiding stressful people
many many things you can do but if your
body is stressed out all the time your
course level behind you will be stuck in
anxiety but the problem is you don't
want to treat it directly you want to
find out why PMS is there a relationship
between your cycle and your mood if so
then you need to support the ovary
because I know some women that can get
very irritable that time of the month or
even certain times of the month if
there's a pattern to it
tyroid the thyroid if it's a physical
problem you you can get depression you
can be apathetic like you don't care
anymore so there's a hormone aspects to
your mood as well that should be
supported to nutrition okay so now we
want to talk about sleep oh my gosh
without sleep you're going to have a lot
of anxiety you're going to have worry
you're going to be in stress mode
because sleep is a natural repair for
for body stress without sleep you can't
rejuvenate you can't recharge the body
and you will have all sorts of mood
issues without sleeping you try to take
your kids to the grocery store when
they're tired they're going to be cranky
okay so and the question is are you
exhausted are you tired or are you
depressed I found mostly you're tired
and you're going to feel the press from
being tired so you don't want to take a
5-hour energy drink to stimulate the
body you want to get more sleep so the
more stress you're under the longer you
need to sleep so don't get seven get
eight hours okay so a lot of problems
with anxiety it can't happen when you're
sleep okay so take a look at the
relationship between your mood and the
physical part of your body
versus just a mental problem and it's
huge and this is what's missed so if
you're having any type of mood problems
look at the nutrition look at the blood
sugars look at if there's a glandular
imbalance look at your sleep and never
treat a symptom find the root cause